SPEAKER 1: To celebrate the
mathematical constant of pi,
we're going to attempt the most
accurate calculation ever
of pi using pies.
Now, before we do our pie-based
pi calculation,
we'll have a quick crash course
in circles and why pi
so important.
Now to do that because we're in
the UK, home of many famous
circles, we've come from the
oldest and greatest circles,
which is, of course, this one.
It's the football circle here at
Knott County Football Club.
Apparently, they are
the world's oldest
Football League club.
SPEAKER 2: How do
you know that?
SPEAKER 1: There's a giant
sign that says that
right behind me.
Which does mean for a while
there, I guess they had no one
else to play, but who knows.
So this circle here, as you can
see, there's two things
going on with the circle.
First of all, there
is the diameter.
So it's this nice, wonderful
straight line here that goes
right through the middle
of the circle.
And the great thing about
diameter is it's a nice
straight line.
So if I wanted to, I could get
a measuring tape, and I could
measure from the start all the
way across here to the finish
and get a very precise
measurement of the distance
across the circle.
Now around here, we have
the circumference.
Now this is a lot harder
to measure.
As you can see, it's
a curved line.
So instead of having
to measure it
directly, we can use pi.
Now pi is the ratio of the
straight line diameter to the
total distance all the way
around the outside.
And if we know that ratio, we
can do one measurement for the
diameter, multiply it by pi, and
get the exact distance all
the way around the outside.
All right, enough messing around
on a football pitch--
let's go get our pies out.
All right, first thing
we need is a circle.
SPEAKER 2: People find
it notoriously
hard to draw circles.
How do you get around
this problem?
SPEAKER 1: Actually, we were
talking to the guy who does
the circle on the pitch for
the football stadium here.
And he does it the same way,
I think, most people do.
He gets a bit of string, makes
the middle bit of the string
remain perfectly still in what
will become the center of the
circle, and then use that to
draw a nice, equal distance
line all the way around.
In fact, I guess that's the best
way to define a circle--
it's the line of all the points
the same distance away
from a center point.
The center point will
be my pen, and the
outside will be the chalk.
All right.
Let's do this.
My goal is to not actually do
any measurements other than
using pies.
So the entire thing is going
to be pie-based.
We get the circumference and the
exact number of pies, give
or take, we get the diameter and
number of pies, divide one
by the other, we get pi.
Pi was historically really
calculated this way because
it's notoriously inaccurate
to try and calculate pi by
measuring a circle.
To get any kind of accuracy on
our final answer, we have to
be as precise as we can be.
This is a mild problem because
I want to go through from the
very edge of the circle, but,
as you can see, I've
positioned all the pies exactly
on the line as if
they're little mini tangents.
So I'm going to have to move
these two out, and then I can
start doing the diameter exactly
on the circumference
there like that.
So that's 84 and 1/3.
264 and 2/3 pies around, where
the diameter is 84 and 1/3 pi.
To get pi, we just divide the
circumference by the diameter.
OK, and if we actually work out
what that is, it equals--
that's pretty good.
Pi from pies, we got 3.13834,
which is approximately 3.14.
So using pies, we've
got pi to be 3.14.
I am a very happy
man right now.
Anything between 3.1 and 3.2,
I would have been happy.
But to get 3.14, I'm
downright ecstatic.
So there you are.
That is officially the world's
most accurate calculation of
pi using pies.
SPEAKER 2: It wasn't really
something we planned to make
part of the video, but as a
lot of you have asked, the
pies we used were donated and
were no longer fit for human
consumption.
So we couldn't give them to
charity, like we did, for
example, with all the
to baked beans that
Heinz donated us earlier.
However, in the spirit of pi
day, we did attempt to make
some kind of gesture, and we
donated 314 pounds, of course
314, to a local charity here in
Nottingham that helps give
food to people in
times of crisis.
Now, a lot of have expressed a
lot of interest in charity,
and we'd really encourage you,
if you're in a position to do
so, to also make a donation.
And we've put some links
under the video.
And because we're all
numberphiles here, why not
make your donation a multiple
of pi in some way?
SPEAKER 1: 16, 17, 18, this is
length L. And that means that
the distance here is 2L.
OK?